well
uh welcome everyone thank you for being
here on a sunday on a very early morning
and i hope during that many
story heads after
the social yesterday
my name is tanya lard i've already been
introduced i
wear many many many hats in the world of
open source
i'm a keyboard sci-fi and design nerd
so
you're in for a bit of a visual trait as
well i hope
and today we're here to talk about key
challenges in the pi data ecosystem and
how more importantly how we can all
make a change for the better or help our
ecosystem thrive
not for
today or tomorrow but hopefully for 10
next 10 20 40
60 years to come
and as someone as as he said i wear way
too many hats in the open source world
and up in the pydate ecosystem
and also as a directory of a company
which is quite labs
we our core mission is building and
sustaining oh well building inclusive
and sustainable open source communities
so
this topic around sustainability and
challenges and how we can make our
ecosystem thrive is very very near and
very dear and near to my heart
and unlike many other talks that i've
given and probably that you've seen
where we have very set sections and like
we're going to start with this follow-up
days and that
uh i'm still going to cover three main
topics
when which one the first one being how
to build a shared vocabulary because
something that i've noticed especially
when we work in
environments that are so diverse uh
words matter words have a meaning but
also depending on what you're talking
about the meaning that a certain word
has might not be exactly the same
meaning that you have for that word
and then the immediate bit will be what
sometimes we call the wrench where is
the pi data ecosystem now what is the
technical and social technical
challenges that we're facing and then
how we can prepare for the road ahead
as i said we're not going to go in a
linear fashion but these are very
interconnected sections these topics are
going to be very interconnected
and hopefully it'll start making sense
as to why
i've put these slides like so
so let's start building our shared
vocabulary by
throwing in a very seemingly innocent
question
what does open source mean to us
i'm not going to ask for a word cloud or
anything just think about it what those
open sources
mean to us
and i know i know many of us come from a
science background or like hard numbers
or like things that are
not unambiguous
so i can see
someone asking like why are we asking
there is a definition right
and that's true we have an open source
definition which is this one not going
to go over every point but this is
maintained by the open source initiative
and through this definition every piece
of software
that claims to be open source
has to comply with this 10
tenants or at least 10 principles
so if any piece of software doesn't
comply with any of this then
by definition it cannot be called open
source
but that is not like this definition is
something we can agree on it is
something that a lot of people have put
together have thought about and have
been
protecting over a couple of decades now
but what i'm really interested in
knowing and i'm very interested in you
reflecting about is
what does open source mean to you
this meaning or whatever this many words
or phrases you have now and your mind
will vary
very bad uh very vastly depending on how
you came to open source
many of you will probably have come to
open source from a closed source
environment first
probably you change jobs and the company
that you've joined
favors or uses open source
for some of us me included open source
almost
20 years ago was the most accessible
way to enter into software because
coming from
a country that is not very rich coming
from a certain background open source
was definitely more accessible than
paying proprietary licenses
at that time
many others
will have found that open source aligns
with their default values and efforts
and it turns out that it's just their
default way of working so they found
their niche under drive and something
that allies with them
but and i also want to add a disclose
here okay so much of what i'm going to
talk about here comes from my own
experience lived experiences from many
of my collaborators
folks within the pi the pi data and open
source ecosystem
we also have to acknowledge that not all
of the interactions in open source are
always
pleasant or enjoyable
for many people open source
unfortunately has also been another
mechanism
of operation benefiting those already in
power and having some privilege
and in many cases open source
again i'm not pointing towards any
individuals or projects
i can guarantee that if you feel
identified i'm not talking about you
but in many cases many folks
sorry
have not been served by the open source
ecosystem as they should have
and we've accepted things as a
collective that work against our
purposes
and is not doing any any favors to any
of us
and again
if i go back
deeper or like a bit more
into
the particular of these conferences and
the projects in which we participate
here
like what does pi data mean to you
will it be the same response
well you're related or associated with
the same words that you would associate
the whole world or the whole collective
of open source
maybe
there is no single answer i've talked to
many people my own answer of the meaning
of
open source and pi data has changed in
the world over time
but if we were to put all of your
collective
meanings and ideas and experiences
together
what more than likely will happen is
we'll start building a highly
interconnected network of stakeholders
tools experiences processes
and the reason is because both open
source and the pi data ecosystem
are complex systems
and they're all based on interactions
that might not be visible or that might
not be all equal or not all equitable
and so far again in the interest of
building our shared vocabulary i've used
the term ecosystem
a lot
so if we go and look and go
what does ecosystem mean or we can get
something like this
and it is very important to mention and
remember that in an ecosystem we're not
just talking about things like
water and trees and bridges
but al there are a lot a lot of elements
some of which are living
some of which are not
but the important part is that every
single element every single part of this
ecosystem plays a part in it
we are always continuously
surrounded by ecosystems
that is how nature self-organizes itself
that is how society self-organizes
itself
for example
shortage out there
is an ecosystem in itself but it's part
of the larger ecosystem of london
and in turn part of the larger ecosystem
of the united kingdom
the pi data umbrella and the pi data
ecosystem
merely intersects with the python
ecosystem
and if you think about it pythonic
system is a very very critical part of
the broader open source ecosystem
so we cannot think that we are going to
do
or impact or change a part of an
if an ecosystem without having having a
ripple effect
in the other ecosystems containing it
everything is just so intertwined and
interconnected that you cannot affect
change in a single part without paying
attention to the others
and to me that is one of the things that
make open source
so exciting
and since we are all here
some sort of pi data participants
citizens users whatever
hat you used to define yourself
let's look at how
our ecosystem is doing today
it is the number one tool set for
scientific computing data science
machine learning and yeah
there are other ecosystems
but they are not as established or as
popular
we have a huge user base um
i'm interested in here ralph gomers who
is my co-conspirator and he said it was
something between 25 to 40 million so
i'm going to believe him
it is behind
some of the major scientific discoveries
and projects
and it has gone from being
an ecosystem mainly favored by academics
and certain french communities to be
part of the mainstream
it is so hard to think about any part of
the industry that has not yet been
touched by open source or by data if
they are in the business
or
area of crunching numbers doing data
science analytics
and as any other ecosystem it's ever
growing and it's ever-changing
great
this is great we've seen
i believe and i want to see more open
source in the world i want to see more
open source developers i want to see
open source thrive
so we're moving in the right direction
there
what are the challenges that we're
facing
there are many
so i've selected a few i've consulted
with home folks with some friends
collaborators
clients
and we've agreed that some of those that
are technical heavy
have been around for a while
well affect end users maintainers and
sometimes every single participant
one of which is packaging
i still have i still have to leave a
full year without seeing a twitter
thread or a reddit thread or
somewhere
where someone will be complaining about
packaging and or try to
install well create a yet another
package manager or yet another standard
for
packaging and metadata
it's a
it's a part of our ecosystem that is
growing in complexity
but we also operate within many
constraints
and resources
and availability
and more recently with
certain regulations in certain parts of
the world increased demand around
securing supply chain
parallelism
historically the
numpy based stack of the pi data system
has been single threaded
there are locations in which packages
like scikit-learn will allow you
to overcome that you might be able to
overcome the gill
but
in its majority
this is single thread there is also a
lot of technical debt that also has been
accumulated because
things change
technology changes sometimes faster than
the hands that we have
to update or refactor some of the
projects that we've been working on
we still have significant parts or
significant chunks of fortune 77 lying
everywhere in our stack
as someone that has to spend time
writing 477
i truly feel for whoever will have to
move from 77 to
mother and fortune
because it's a huge it's a huge labor
and it will not affect just one package
but if you think about making changes in
the real real innards of numpy that's
going to have again a ripple effect in
all of the packages that depend on it
which is
a lot of our pi data ecosystem
performance and scale as
we're pushing the boundaries of what we
can do
with our worry
as we push the boundaries on how much
data we're collecting how much data
we're operating with we're also pushing
constant continuously to have
massive scale and improve performance
and those are all technical heavy
but they're not the only type of
challenges that we're facing again
because again remember with an ecosystem
we are talking about
living and not living elements
so
again this the diversity of these
elements within our ecosystem is
extremely broad
i could try and capture a list
all of the elements that we have and i
will probably fail
and again as in complex systems we have
interlocking crisis
each of which will have components that
also affect or come from a bigger
challenge
and we that's why we just cannot focus
on one single challenge aim to fix it
and call it quits
some of the biggest challenges that we
have is again
around the people that build open source
the people
that consume open source and
our capacity to make our ecosystem
thrive
where is we still have a long way to go
in terms of community safety
this comes to
code of conducts are great
i'm so happy that most projects have now
a code of conduct but that in itself is
not enough to make our community safe
and welcoming
we also have to think about
human and environmental diversity
and this also means reaching people
where they are
whether it is from a technical
standpoint using standpoint or
all of the spectrum of human diversity
leadership
again we have to rethink what leadership
means
and move away from this is how we've
done things
for the last 10 20 decades
10 20 years or the last couple of
decades
and again
a lot of the tools that we've developed
in the open source ecosystem not just in
our pi data it has had the motto of
developers
for developers
and we need to move into
paradigms that are more around user
experience
send access center approach because
again that will bring the folks that
have historically not been participating
in our community
again plus from from the past this is
probably one of my favorite readings
because
nadia released this
report in
2016 called roads and bridges don't see
in library of our digital infrastructure
i tried to i talked about that every
time i i can
um but because important part of this is
that when this report
went out in the world it actually
shown some light about the like the
woeful state of our ecosystem like how
overworked
how undervalued and how under
paid and underfunded
our folks are and our digital
infrastructure is
and
of course people were terrified because
it's really really hard to measure the
actual cost of open source of open
infrastructure
and since then
as we expect as we're technologists
we've seen
loads of initiatives
um aimed at getting funding to open
source maintainers
things like this
all right
one off
donations
um
for those of you that are into twitch
maybe this will bring some
uh some feelings
but we've seen a lot of well intended
one-off financial or in-kind support
from big corps
from individuals from startups
and if you think about it it makes sense
when we are in a crisis
we reach out
to our wallet our phone
our paypal for those of you that are
into crypto probably our crypto walls or
your crypto wallets
and
donate some money it feels good i'm not
going to say that it doesn't feel good
it feels good
but again
in the economic and cultural context in
which we live
we've been conditioned to equate money
to good
and sustainable
so there is where the focus is right now
and
the problem is that although all of
these donations and all of this is
sponsoring folks through
github sponsors is very very well manned
and very well intended
there is a huge part of the puzzle still
missing
very few
individuals or very few organizations
follow through destinations
to see
that it really had an impact
did it really make the maintainers lives
better
did it really helped the project thrive
i'm not saying that if you're making a
donation of
five quid once a year that entitles you
to go to the maintainers and ask what
did you do with my five quid
that's an entirely different boat
but again
this i'm all up for paying maintainers
that is one of the big parts
that we do for uh within queenside labs
with our maintainers to work
either full-time part-time or protected
time in open source i'm all for it
that's great but funding it itself is
not going to fix all of our problems
and
i like to use this analogy because most
of the times what we're trying to do is
we're trying to cover a pothole with
duct tape
that's not going to hold that's not
going to fix all of that interlocking
challenges
that i mentioned before
and again the reason is because we don't
live in a simple system
there is a word and that i use again a
lot that goes back to the post
world war ii
era
where folks started defining what
associate technical system is
if you are into
ethical ai or ethics in ai this is a
word that is coming more and more
because it pertains to systems again
involving
humans and some sort of tech i'm not
talking about computers but like any any
tools any technology
as well as processes
and workflows
and you cannot separate them because
it is awfully inappropriate
an easier way to digest this
again
you probably you'll you're start you'll
start seeing all the connections
everything is connected
everything is interlocking everything is
intertwined
but this is a really
this is how the leads business school
actually defines social technical
systems
so
following that line of thought or that
circle of thought or network of thought
our system is not just an ecosystem
as a
social technical system
formed by
subsystems
we have people
we have infrastructure
we have technology
we have culture
processes and goals and metrics
we operate in probably a digital or a
physical infrastructure and we share
cultural assumptions we share values and
we share in ours
and why is this important
this is important because we have to
start building or rebuilding for the
upstream
and what i mean when i say building for
this upstream is building for
sustainability
building for
us to be able to change and face those
challenges
i know we like reinventing the will
and sometimes we like creating
our way or my project way or my company
way
but here we can take inspiration from
the corporate world
the corporate world has a concept called
corporate sustainability
has gone around for
many years i think
uh the burnt land report
was about was released around 1987 and
it was one of the first reports to
define what sustainability is and
how we should build for sustainability
meaning build
for the future
for longevity without compromising
their resources and the decisions
of the future populations or the future
systems
so the corporate world has figured it
out kind of
and the reason they keep investing in
corporate sustainability plans is
because the benefits are worth it
some of these benefits include increased
innovation increase collaboration better
communication
reliable secure
reliable and secure supply chain and if
you think of all that that is what we
want that is what we need in open source
so what can we do there
we can
put our open source hud adopt open
source way
and build on what the corporate world
has figured out
as a refresher
10 seconds probably
five seconds
remember these are all of the subsystems
all of the interlocking parts
and let's see how
we can rethink
each of these interlocking systems
for
us to start building an open source
sustainability plan
first of all
community
safety i
it's not easy to build a diverse
inclusive safe community it takes a lot
of time it takes a lot of intention a
lot of emotional labor
and
it is not easy to build an inclusive
community
or an inclusive uh diverse sorry
contributor base if people don't feel
safe
behavior is
like
personally directed criticism
sexualized imagery or comments bigoting
bike shedding hateful language
unwelcome attention
all of the sections that have happened
not once not in isolation within
the
whole collective of open source
undermine the trust required to create a
psychologically safe environment for all
and this is what we need we need to be
able to trust each other
to uplift each other
again when i'm talking about diversity
it is
easy to focus on some visible
characteristics
it's easy to count
in some cases binaries
but i'm not talking about just those
binaries or those basically
countable diverse layers i'm thinking we
have to bring all of the full spectrum
of human diversity that includes
geography
one of our biggest challenges is that
the global south is still
open source consumer more than open
source innovators or open source leaders
how can we build these communities that
are part of our system but are not
growing at the same pace as others
i would say a way to approach that
not the one and probably not the best
one not optimal but if you think about
it
all of our tutorials documentation
oh uh op ads everything is in english
we still have a huge user base
that
don't speak english
i know there are a lot of narratives
that say well
if you're learning python it should be
easy to learn english
right
now try to do that when the reason why
you're getting into tech and it's a very
very bad reason is because you want to
give your family a better quality of
life
and you're doing that at night when
taking care of children
or
your elder parents or you are fleeing
your country because it's a war
when do we expect these people
to have extra time
to learn
english
again we're going to get to non-people
diversity in a bit
and then
i know some people are going to say hey
tanya but like really do we need
diversity yes we need adversity and even
if not for if if you
don't want to believe me if um
there are people that are cl
are a bit dubious about all of the
research that has demonstrated time and
time again the diverse teams are more
innovative we have more ideas
do it for the sake of
adhering to the open source initiative
definition
and that means
no discrimination against persons or
groups
by not including
these folks
are we
complying to the values and the
definitions
of the open source initiative
we're not
again
now let's rethink leadership
and there is this question what is a
leader in open source
if you start thinking about what is a
leader in open source
it starts becoming
really complicated pretty soon
and because we don't like open source is
not formed in a traditional structure
let's say like in the corporate world
where you have very set roads like cto
ceo director intern
manager manager of managers we don't
have
those roles
we talk
so much
about mentoring new contributors we talk
a lot about mentoring those folks that
we want to bring in our projects
but
who talks about mentoring leaders
who's talking about
okay let's sit down identify those
critical roles beyond benevolent
dictator for life
let's think about
those functions without which my project
or my ecosystem might not be able to
thrive
build a mentorship program
and allow folks to see a clear path
towards leadership
whatever it is
ultimately
we should start and then this is a very
it's a complete change in mindset
because we
very much interact with corporate world
academia where these roles are defined
we have to start thinking in terms of
verbs and not nouns
i have to start thinking about the
functions that each of us
facilitates in our projects and our
ecosystem
things like organizes community
things like triage and welcomes new
contributions
and move from the concept of we need to
build
a leadership pipeline
because we need to be able to skip a
skill pipeline ultimately all of this
goes back to skills skills can be
learned but we need to mentor folks
similar to when you're applying to a job
more than likely during your interview
process or whatever it is
you're gonna ask what does your career
progression look like
it's natural
you don't want to end up in a place
where you're gonna be sitting
in the same role for the next 10 years
five years
with no clear direction
if we have a clear
leadership skill pipeline and mentorship
programs
these folks that we're inviting
can see a clear path to where they are
going
they can see a clear path
of value exchange
for them
the project and the community
the problem is
and this is a big big big problem that i
have
we've based a lot or a lot of projects
based their leadership and the way they
do things based on the concept of
meritocracy
and i have loads of problems with that
because in principle
in principle and in theory conceptually
it is a good idea
like you prove you're married
you are in whatever you're earning
you get value for that
but what i've seen
in many cases is that meritocracy
doesn't work like that
what pauses for meritocracy again
translates to hostility
to
towards new contributors towards new
ideas and keep reinforcing our echo
chain chambers
so if your concept of meritocracy cannot
be defined beyond
i'll know when i see it and if i'll be
able to evaluate if this credits enough
merit then
i just not thought it very well as a
project or as an individual or as a
community
and we've seen this time and time again
we've seen folks that come in
have very valuable very complex skills
like
community management
project management
i don't know if any of you have ever
done project management for i've done it
and coordinating like that amount of
information people priorities making
sure that things are hunted in time and
too high certain extremely is extremely
challenging
but because folks are performing these
other functions
that are not necessarily related to
crunching code
they're often dismissed or
just not even considered as
potential leaders in our projects or
communities
and we're missing huge critical skills
there
so what do we owe each other
in
open source
which are the values around which we
should be building
to tackle all of these changing mindsets
changing processes changing metrics
empowerment transparency and kindness
if you look at that
if
all of these recommendations are
document
what you're doing what your processes
are
how someone steps into leadership what
you're what a leader means to you what
skills do you need you're being
transparent
at the same time if you put on
mentorship not just for newcomers
but about folks that might become your
leaders or are already in position of
leadership you're empowering them
and you're also treating everyone with
kindness with the same
acknowledgement and value proposition
regardless of what skills they're like
bringing on
we're coming now to a very challenging
part
in case one of the main
questions i get asked or
folks like me that works so much on
getting resources time structural
process and longevity longevity to open
source is like
okay
now
translate that into corporate numbers
that i can crunch
statistics that i can crunch
so i know like the value that open
source and investing in open source and
giving you this
talent or money or expertise will bring
me
it's extremely hard this comes again
from an uh from another
extract of natick well
again because our ecosystem is just so
complex
it's a social technical ecosystem with
so many moving and interlocking pieces
the impact of digital infrastructure
our open source is extremely difficult
to measure
we have some proxies
we have some data
some
and nadia has this hypothesis that if we
had better metrics we were better
equipped to describe the economic and
social societal
impact of digital infrastructure in open
source
now
and this is very very tricky as well
because
let's think about it how are we
measuring open source how are we
measuring impact how are we measuring
again who what what are what is our
measuring stick on
who's a leader in open source
right now
and remember what gets counted count
thought is
universal
that's what counts right
people like hard data
if you're doing whatever role you're
doing you're going to be asked to give
some sort of
metrics
but think about it think about open
source again
who gets the power to count what gets
counted
right
all of this counting is based on the
platforms that we are using to build the
software
and
build community
examples github
i spend so much of my time there
gitlab discord slack now orbit
but again this power
gets placed on the people who are doing
the counting and make decisions about
what data
and what methodology to use
what instead if we shifted that power
back to the community
and we were able to fully support
fully
like have a full picture of who
and how
really supports and maintains all of
open source
that means again
thinking about how we make
all of the labor festival
and i take inspiration learnings from so
many places
there is this
fabulous book that has changed a lot how
i think about data
from a feminist lens
and exactly that making all labor
visible is the principle seven
and it help will help us to make to
build a more equitable community
we need to represent and acknowledge
all labor in open source
we need to be able to empower those that
are filling those foundational roles and
skills
and we need to empower them by giving
them acknowledge and making their value
explicit
i recently learned i was recently
talking to one of the wordpress core
developers they don't use
uh didn't use github they use something
else and i have forgotten what it is
i found the principle very interesting
when during doing a pull request or the
equivalent of a pull request
they are able to annotate
whatever it is with props they have a
very special annotation called props
and they use that to acknowledge all
sorts of contributions to whatever made
that feature or pull request or bug or
rfd happen
that includes props to
whoever open the issue whoever
ship heard the discussion whoever
overviewed or coordinated the release
that way
they've gone around it
and they are counting in an imperfect
but at least visible manner
who is performing what
and
they ha like their labor is attached to
the code to the commit because they made
that happen
there are some other proxies like all
contributors mods if you've seen it
around in some projects that allows you
to
soft acknowledge some of these non-code
or non-technical functions
but that doesn't get attached again to
what is counted ultimately
which are lines of code either deleted
prs issues open
once again
processes we have processes for
everything and if we don't document this
processes
we cannot think about sustainability
think about documentation of
self-service onboarding remote
redundancy the source of truth
documenting again this is skills and
processes and maintain your project
and again
all of this is based on empowerment
transparency and kindness
it's the same with infrastructure
so now you're seeing where i'm going
there is wherever we look even if it's
infrastructure
we want to try and remove
monocultures we want to make whatever
we're building more usable more
applicable we want to ensure access
because again that's going to bring
folks with your next perspectives that's
going to make us more sustainable
maintain install
when you're building a new tool
migrating to a new platform
we have to think how is this
adding or removing to the already
massive backlog of my fellow maintainers
building empowerment transparency and
kindness
but how do we even start it's really
really hard to get started
that's why i want to start by asking a
question what does open source mean to
you
identify how many hats you are
wearing and ecosystem where do you fit
what is your play
what is your role
identify your constraints because that's
very important like it's very like it's
number one premise to know where and
within which bounds you're operating
and therefore what you can contribute to
or contribute with
again empowerment
transparency
and kindness to yourself
and to your fellows
tiffany harris
has perfectly summarized all of the
variety
of contributions that we can make
as an individual corporation
organization ally champion non-profit
fiscal sponsor
most of what you're providing will fall
in either of these three categories
talent
as an individual your skills as an
organization
your organization unique skills or
resources
that's why
bodies like known focus that provide
legal knowledge and legal advice and
mechanisms for projects to receive
donations
are substantial
because they're reducing that toil and
that overhead from the folks that are
doing the day-to-day maintenance
time
time is precious
if you can spend time organizing events
like this mentoring others advising
others
and treasure
it's okay i know i said before
probably one of the nations are not the
best but sometimes
within our constraints
that's all we have
and that's fine
but again
keep in mind that that's not the only in
one solution
these are things that you can
you can shift around build on depending
again if you're an organization an
individual a champion or an ally
and more importantly how can you
contribute
listen to people and meet them where
they are
if you are a corporation or trying to
convince your organization to make a big
donation or play a burger part
in open source
listen to the maintainers listen to
folks like leah and jim that are part of
known focus and know better about what
our projects need
participate meaningfully
engage with folks if you're hiring open
source maintainers in your company
and your expectation is that they're
going to dedicate time
to maintain their open source projects
add that as a contractual clause
for their protection for your protection
and that demonstrates
some of your commitment to open source
clarify value exchange again
we like like i know as an organization
it's really real hard and justifying
budget and time and resources is
critical
what are we getting and why
think about the world where
all of the open source projects that you
depend on disappeared
what would you lose
many of us wouldn't be able to serve our
customers to perform our job to hire
people without open source
so
if python were to disappear
that like a big chunk of our revenue and
profit will be gone
those are hard numbers that we can
operate with those are hard numbers that
we can take to our leadership in the
corporate world and see this is the
potential impact
it's not perfect
but it's something
again
empowerment transparency and kindness
and as i like false circles
as i like
probably you'll have noticed
sci-fi and i take a lot of inspiration
from many different and diverse
resources
i want to go back to the first question
that i asked and this is now century to
me
what does open source mean to me
for my fellow
sci-fi
aficionados
you'll probably have seen this without
knowing the actual word
of an accumul
a cumenopolis
it is a very recurrent theme in many
sci-fi books and films
but basically it's a future world where
every square inch of a planet is covered
by a city
for those of you that love star wars
chorus gund is an example of this
it's the heart and capital of the galaxy
that's where the jedi temple was
if you are more into
isak asimov's narrative or of sci-fi of
sci-fi
probably you're familiar with trentor
but this like if you think about karen
scott and toronto they're all
they're both well-established
like monopolies
they're built completely
it's covered right you can also think
about
gotham as it's some sort of a small
version of like monopolies if you are
more into that type of comics
but one of my favorite books ever
is
uh
uh what is his name
philip text
do android dream of electric [ __ ] that
was turned into film i'm not going to go
into how about it those the film 30
percent big but
in in the film especially we see
neo la which is
not an ecumenopolis per se
but it's building
towards it
what's interesting is that you can see
big cities like los angeles or neo los
angeles
that have started building like these
sky creepers and everything you can see
how everything has been tangled up and
built up based on
gentrification faults functions that
need to be performed
but
we still see
areas that have not grown or developed
as much as
for example neola when it comes to these
wastelands
there are still parts that need growing
and this is here
this is where i feel we are
we are building
bridges and we're starting to build very
well-established
big ecu monopolies we still have a lot
of wastelands or areas that have not
caught up yet
and
if our dream is building
something like this an ecumenopolis a
really interconnected
sustainable
ecosystem
we have to start looking at those areas
that are underdeveloped
and it's a lot
and we need
all the help
all the hands all the resources
all the empowerment
and kindness and transparency that we
can put together
thank you very much
i am tiny alert
i hope you enjoyed this very
networked not linear
presentation
and
i know i'm not naming all of the people
that have helped me to build my vision
on identifying the challenges in our
ecosystem but
i always like to acknowledge them and
affect them because
they are the people that have treated me
with kindness and welcomed me into the
community
thank you and
oh
i killed them
and we'll see
i will be around for any questions or a
chance because i went over time and i am
sorry
[Applause]